hey guys it's alex and today i'm gonna
be trying to recreate some secret menu
items from taco bell so a secret menu
food is an
item that a restaurant makes or used to
make that isn't on their menu
i personally love taco bell so i'm gonna
try to recreate some of their most
infamous secret menu items first up
we'll be making the waffle taco
and then the legendary and elusive
enchorito
but first let's see if we can actually
get these all right i'm here at the taco
bell drive-through
hi how are you hi um can i get two
waffle tacos
you don't have that no you aren't
keeping a secret
a waffle taco so then can i instead get
two encharitos
wait are you sure oh i
don't have it how long yeah like two
years now
two years late i'm late
so the waffle taco was impossible to get
but don't worry i've got that recipe
covered and as for the enterito
i think i've got something pretty close
let's check it out
all right we've got the goods
oh yes we've got two beef and bean
burritos beautiful just as i remembered
i actually don't have many memories of
taco bell because i feel like the only
time i go to taco bell
is when i'm really drunk i'm going to
smother it in this red sauce
interesting that they gave me melted
cheese so that's like gonna be melted
cheese on top that is
art it's got a good bite here in the
middle some of that sauce
tastes like taco bell you know it is
good
but it's not nearly as good as the real
deal and chorito
and i know i can do better so let's get
cooking
so to kick things off we've got the
waffle taco
now this was a very short-lived secret
menu
item at taco bell in fact you could only
get it for
a year i like waffles and i like tacos
but
do they belong together i'm optimistic
so first up i've got a
thawed frozen waffle and i'm gonna pop
it in some hot oil
for a quick fry so i'm just frying this
waffle up for about 30 seconds each side
just so it's a little bit golden brown
but still pliable
she's perfect so now i'm gonna drain off
some of that excess oil
and then pop it right on our taco shaper
and i'm just gonna form this into a nice
little taco shape
next one so legend has it the way the
waffle taco was born
was that a taco bell worker fried up a
frozen waffle
and then put it in the chalupa holder
was it magic or
was it a curse next guy goes in our
little
makeshift chalupa holder our waffle taco
shape is done moving on to our sausage
patty so i'm just gonna form
our sausage into about the same size
as our waffle taco shell okay that looks
like it's about right
popping it in to fry if you're a lover
of breakfast food this is a fun new take
on like a breakfast sandwich if you're
sick
of the classic biscuit or
muffin taco
we're gonna make a waffle taco
so these sausages are looking nice and
brown so what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to kind of cut this sausage
patty
down the middle so that i'm able to
place it nicely into our waffle
taco shell this is same boat as
mcgriddle
for sure but it's just an outlier
for the taco bell menu i don't know if
all these fast food chains have some
sort of like connection like maybe they
are
like at the top kind of like switching
foods there's some sort of fast food
illuminati going on
up at the top i don't know are they in
cahoots you don't know
so for the last component of our waffle
taco
we've got some scrambled eggs cheesy
scrambled eggs
i'm gonna scramble up some eggs
pour them into a pan with some butter
gonna season with a little salt
i don't even know taco bell had eggs
like where did they get the egg
did they just go to the grocery store so
now i'm gonna top our scrambled eggs
with some
cheddar cheese and then put a little lid
on this to get it all nice and melty
eggs are looking good i'm just gonna
yeah just
pop these right on top and for the final
touch i'm gonna drizzle these guys in a
little good old maple syrup
the moment of truth let's see how this
waffle taco
really is i have a fork knife here but
i'm gonna eat it like
i would any taco with the hands
it's delicious it's every classic
breakfast food that you love
formed into a taco shape i appreciate
that
it's pretty easy to eat if it happened
to make
another appearance on the taco bell menu
i wouldn't be mad at it
but that's up to the taco bell gods but
in the meantime
you can make it yourself at home and
it's pretty easy and
pretty delicious all right breakfast is
out of the way and now it's time to make
the main event
the whole enchilada if you will the
encharito
all right to kick things off with the
taco bell and chorito we're gonna start
by
making the classic red sauce so to start
i'm going to
bloom our spices we've got some paprika
some chili powder some garlic powder
some cumin
onion powder and cayenne i should add
that this is just my interpretation of
the taco bell red sauce
the real recipe is also a secret but
i think i can give them a run for their
money so i'm just blooming these spices
in a little bit of oil until they're
nice and
fragrant i feel like the sauces at taco
bell are one of their
most popular items and they're not even
a real menu item
all right to the spices i'm adding some
tomato sauce
looking saucy already all right now i'm
gonna add in some white vinegar
some salt and some water now i'm gonna
bring this to a boil reduce it to a
simmer
cover it and then let it cook until it's
a little bit thicker
and then we've got our red sauce moving
on to our refried beans
people really enjoy them actually my
best friend
loves the beans so much she thinks
they're the best beans on earth
i don't know if i'd go that far but
but they are pretty good fun fact the
taco bell refried beans are actually
vegan when normal refried beans are
usually made with lard
so first i've got some olive oil in my
pan i'm adding in some onions
and some garlic next i have some cumin
and chili powder we've got our bowl of
beans going in
a bay leaf and some salt now i'm going
to add some
water and we're going to simmer this for
about 15 minutes
all right our beans are looking real
good mmm they smell really good too
nice and spicy so i'm gonna take the bay
leaf out
and then using a potato masher i'm just
gonna start
mashing these guys up you know fast food
gets a bad rep but
i think it's one thing that really
unites us as a
world you can find a taco bell anywhere
you could find a mcdonald's anywhere
it's the universal thing
it's like our own version of a watering
hole like the animals go
converge over the watering hole we are
the animals
converging in the drive-through line wow
the beans are looking real good
now i'm gonna add in some lime juice
give this another last little stir
here we go uh we're in business baby i'm
gonna open up my own taco bell
alex bell all right the beans are good
we are ready to move on listen i got a
little beef with taco bell
just kidding it's beef time okay so i
have a little oil in the pan i'm adding
in
my ground beef gonna start breaking this
down
and browning it up break it down brown
it up break it down brown it up break it
down brown it up
i'm gonna season this beef with a little
salt chili powder paprika
cayenne coriander cumin garlic powder
onion powder just stir this up and get
it
all nice and coated in those spices so
now i'm just going to sprinkle on some
flour
and our beef stock right in there
so now i'm just gonna cook this up for
about five to seven minutes until
most of the water has reduced and it's
thickened up so this part might seem a
little bit
weird because it is but in order to get
this classic
taco bell thinned out beef texture i
am going to pulverize our beef with an
immersion blender
this is kind of like a hot pot of beef
and there could be a little bit of a
splash zone so
just be careful putting it in
yeah this is so weird i wonder if they
do this in taco bell
oh there that is the good stuff
that's the sound
i think we're pretty good gonna use this
for a smoothie later
but really that looks like more like
taco bell beef that was an important
step
beautiful if you don't have an immersion
blender you could always pulse it in a
food processor or
just really really mash it up with your
fork time to assemble this thing we've
got all of our components
so we're going to start with a layer of
beans
i'm going to try not to overfill
my anchorito which i usually tend to do
when i make any sort of burrito at home
next our layer of onions the almost
unrecognizable pulverized ground beef
now i'm gonna roll this baby up
when you fold a burrito you'll just go
in on the sides and then
you gotta really just commit to it all
right and i'm putting it seam side down
in our pan and i'm just gonna repeat the
process there we go
last one in wow look at that so i'm
gonna smother these in our
delicious red sauce oh yeah look at that
all nice and saucy and finally our
cheddar cheese
right on top cheese bae all right so now
i'm gonna bake this at 375 for about
five minutes until that cheese is nice
and melty and then we'll try this thing
and see if our enchirito is a
go or a no
not as fast as the taco bell drive-thru
i should add but
just as delicious maybe more let's take
one
of these babies out of here it's pretty
big
let's cut it open oh yeah gonna get
a little piece with some sauce on it all
right
here goes nothing it's really good
definitely a lot like the one we tried
early on today but i would say a little
more sophisticated we've got some deeper
flavors there
and everything just kind of comes
together nicely we've got some
size here we've got a lot of depth of
flavor
the cat's out of the bag the encharito
is a secret no more
if you're feeling saucy i recommend you
make this one and if you do be sure to
tag me i'd love to see your work and
also comment down below and let me know
what other secret menu items
you want me to make all right see you
next time and throw in a crunchwrap
supreme
we don't have contracts anymore either
what i'm just kidding
oh yes
you